happy birthday to you
june 2020 and school pupils wish the
visiting prime minister a happy birthday
the same day his wife carrie dozens of
his colleagues and even their interior
designer attended a birthday celebration
with cake inside 10 downing streets
now finally boris johnson's the subject
of a police investigation weeks after
reports emerged of parties in or near
downing street during lockdown i can
confirm
that the met is now investigating
a number of events that took place at
downing street and whitehall
in the last two years
in relation to potential breaches
of kovit-19 regulations
the move comes after officers working in
downing street gave evidence to an
existing internal government inquiry
headed by civil servant sue gray
that process has quite properly involved
sharing information continuously with
the metropolitan police so i welcome the
mets decision to conduct its own
investigation because i believe this
will help to give the public the clarity
it needs and help to draw a line under
matters the opposition labour parties
repeated calls for boris johnson to
resign suggesting he'd lied to
parliament
just weeks ago mr speaker the prime
minister told this house
there was no party
how does the pay master general explain
that
i know across the country people know
enough they have made up their minds
about the prime minister so when will
his party catch up the prime minister's
popularity and credibility ratings have
tanked with every new report of alleged
rule breaking one new survey suggests 62
percent of the population think he
should step down
yeah i'll be honest i always vote for
boris but he's got to go in he broke the
rules you've got to go that's taken so
long there's been so many controversies
so far and hasn't kicked him out of
office so it's a bit of a teflon pm at
the moment but many conservative mps
have insisted they'll wait until sue
gray's report is finished before
deciding whether to trigger a leadership
contest so the latest twist could be a
lifeline for the prime minister of
course the irony is that the
inquiry being conducted by the cabinet
office being led by sue gray who is a
senior whitehall civil servant will
probably now be delayed because
these criminal proceedings are underway
the criminal investigation is underway
so in that sense boris johnson actually
has some breathing space breathing space
perhaps but with every day that passes
he knows there could be more damaging
revelations and now there's the
possibility of police action too nadeem
baba al jazeera